In five years, we could well be spending one
trillion dollars a year, interest only, on the debt
young people are getting fucked!
And we also asked voters who they would pick
for the US Senate seat
Democrat incumbent Martin Heinrich, Republican
contractor Mick Rich
or Libertarian Gary Johnson, also New Mexico's
former governor.
We're going to have knocked on over a hundred
thousand doors which is very significant
so we've got a pretty good ground game and
we'll just have to see.
I'm out campaigning for Gary Johnson, I'm
volunteering.
Yeah he's a very personable guy, very intelligent
guy.
I'm glad he's back in New Mexico, maybe he'll
stay this time.
I'm hoping we elect him for Senate.
I wish he'd run for governor, quite honestly.
I'm just doing some volunteer work today for
Gary Johnson for Senate.
Not interested.
Thank you sir.
Will you be voting for Gary?
Oh yeah!
That's great, thank you.
I don't know what kind of chance he has, but...
We do have a set script that we go on.
"Hello voter, my name is Justin, I'm a volunteer
concerned with corruption in Washington DC.
Do you consider yourself more conservative,
liberal or independent?"
Hey Donald how are you doing? My name is David.
I'm a volunteer concerned with corruption
in Washington DC
and wanted to know do you lean more conservative,
liberal or independent?
Conservative.
Conservative, okay, excellent.
Try and hook them a little bit more, and tell
them a little about what Gary did as Governor.
As a Republican Governor Gary Johnson vetoed
750 bills, lowered taxes
and cut the budget by 10% without firing any
employees.
Can we count on your vote for such conservative
Gary Johnson?
No.
If they bite on that it segues into a whole
Gary Johnson blurb.
Gary Johnson was a former governor of New
Mexico and during his time-
I'm in New Mexico of course, he's a pothead.
Would you think Gary Johnson, the former Republican
governor or Mart Heinrich
who would you think is a better option in
that race?
Gary, I'd vote for.
Gary Johnson, okay, excellent.
I'm not going to vote for him so don't worry
about it.
Okay.
Bye.
Bye bye.
Your call has ended, please enter your results
now.
A quick question, have you ever smokes pot?
I do occasionally, yes
and yes we should legalize marijuana and in
1999 I advocated-
We'll get to that in just a moment, we'll
come back to it.
Mr Rich, have you ever smokes pot?
Man, when I talked about we need to let our
young-
Yes or no, come on, when was the last time
that Martin smoked and when was the last-
Have you ever talked about it?
Uhm, it would be hard to remember the last
time.
You remember?
Well the presidential race in 2016 was still
having to tell people who I was
and the disbelief that went along with you're
actually running for President of the United States
and you're a what, a Libertarian and what's
that and who are you
and why were you even born?
As opposed to running for US Senate, having
served as Governor here for 8 years
and having everybody know who you are.
And so it's been a lot of fun really.
And I'm getting to run for the US Senate in
a three month race, what a gift!
There's a misunderstanding when it comes to
public lands east of the Mississippi.
What is public lands?
Well everybody thinks public lands are rotarian
areas but...
but they're checkerboard lands.
This right here?
This is checkerboard?
Yup.
As you look out over the horizon, it's red
squares and black squares.
And I do mean, geometric red squares and black
squares.
The red squares being public, the black squares
being private.
So what you'll see oftentimes is a rancher,
so and so and so and so
has 20 thousand private acres and 20 thousand
leased acres.
How does it always work out 20 thousand / 20
thousand?
Well because it's checkerboard.
So they pass legislation that says that you
have to be able to access public lands.
Well fuck how do you access a black square
without going through a red square?
You can't, it's not possible.
Why not sell those lands to the landholders
and put them on the uh
put them on the tax rolls, or property tax
rolls
as opposed to the lease that currently takes place.
We have to cut back on military spending.
I was more outspoken than any Governor in
the country regarding school choice.
I'm a  Gary Johnson, Libertarian.
I gotta tel you if you haven't ever done it.
Climbing to one of the tops of one of those
peaks, it's a scramble
but oh my gosh, there's some serious pucker
in doing that stuff.
If you were to slip, which you're not gonna
slip but if you were to slip you'd die.
My mom would say to me that she didn't,
'where do you get it Gary? where do you get
it?'
'Well it's you mom'
'No it's not me Gary, it's you, where did
you get it?'
'What's the matter with you son?'
Don't- reelect Gary for governor, this is
my mother,
reelect Gary so he doesn't go to Mount Everest
please.
'Cause he's going.
Renewables might be 50 percent of the grid,
terrific, terrific.
Right now there's a cap on the amount of wages
that get subject to social security,
raise that cap.
Recently there was a military budget increase
by about 100 billion.
Yeah.
Udall and Heinrich both voted for it and I
was wondering what your thoughts were on that.
Well I would have voted against it, against
it,
believing that the biggest issue that's facing
the country right now is the deficit and the debt.
After he was governor, he went on a little
vacation and climbed Mount Everest.
The hope that remains within me is to potentially
win
and if that were to happen, or it would be
really close,
potentially there could be thousands, thousands
of candidates nationwide
that will line up next election cycle, that
would not have done that otherwise
but for my results for example.
I loved the last few months, but if I don't
end up being US Senator from New Mexico I'm done.
I will ski a hundred days this season at Taus,
I will ride the continental divide mountain
bike race for the third time
and I'll get back to the dream that I hoped
my life would be at some point
and I do that live that dream, not by mistake.
Nobody should play any violins for me, right?
We also asked voters who they'd pick for US
Senate seat, Heinrich came in with 40%,
Rich in second with 28%
and Johnson close behind with 22%
However 11% said they're still undecided,
our political expert said this race could
be closer than we think.